remember we first met the strip club in
s you can I say you were headlining La
Hoya I was a door man yes right I think
Diaz was Diaz was there I believe so
yeah I think he was there right I knew
Diaz so he goes hey let's go to the
strip club with Joe so then we go to the
strip club and I wanted to go like I'm
from San Diego I know the ropes okay
that's not really what happened no but
we sat there okay and then there were
gang members there and then we I don't
know what the problem was but there was
a problem between I'll tell you the
problem there's one of the Gang members
was dating one of the strippers okay and
when he was over there talking to the
stripper you went over and tried to get
the stripper to give you a lap dance and
I said Bobby what the are you doing and
you're like oh shut the up this
nothing's going to happen they ain't
going to do I go okay I'm out of
here so I said I'm leaving you can
either come with me or not and you
barely got in my car you were Dilly
dallying and someone had to yell at you
and then we got you in the car and we
took off I hey Bobby you were going to
get a shot but but also if she's working
there she's on the clock no just hear